we're here today to present to you
opening the black box by ben fowler and
chelsea mizzy
my name is ben fowler uh i'm on the
predictive analytics team uh at
southeast toyota finance
and things that i really like to do are
write python
learn new things and then in my spare
time
be on the golf course
my name is chelsea mizzy and i'm a
machine learning lead
also at southeast toyota finance i have
a background in statistics
having studied statistics in undergrad
and i have a master's in analytics
i work remotely living in denver
colorado and i like to spend my time
skiing and mountain biking outside of
work
so the intent of this presentation is to
really talk about
how can you as data scientists or
as a business user understand complex
machine learning models we're going to
talk a little bit about techniques that
you can use for
explaining them using open source
approaches
and we'll also then conclude with the
demonstration of how you can visualize
model interpretability to business end
users
so a quick walkthrough of the agenda
first we'll begin with the data the
description of the data set including
the sources
the source of our data and the features
then we'll move on to feature
engineering which is the overview of
the methods applied to columns for pair
for modeling
next we'll talk about feature selection
which is a discussion of the techniques
used to select the optimal set of
features
moving on we'll talk about our actual
final model
um including regular regulatory
compliance constraints
and interpretation of the model and then
finally
we're going to talk about display in the
model so we'll um
we'll have an example with streamlit a
solution for model interpretation
so for consumer privacy reasons we
decided to use an open source dataset
found on kaggle for this project as
opposed to using our internal sctf
data this data is called credit
default risk the target was a binary
feature predicting
payment difficulties there were 346
features relating to credit bureau data
payment history applicant assets
and a few external data inputs one
strength of this data is that it mimics
real-world data with having about 1.2
million rows of data and then in terms
of data exclusion
which i'll speak to more thoroughly
later on
we excluded applicant features relating
to gender
age and family status
okay so feature engineering after we
clean the data and took time to
understand the data
through exploratory data analysis the
next step is feature engineering
to borrow a quote from jason brownlee
feature engineering is the process of
transforming
raw data into features that better
represent the underlying problem
to the predictive models resulting in
improved model accuracy on unseen data
so for this project ben and i performed
four different types of feature
engineering techniques
including label encoding where we
convert labels
into numeric sequences one hot encoding
where we create binary indicators for
categorical inputs
mean target target encoding in which we
replace values with the mean
of the dependent feature and then weight
of evidence in which we bend the feature
and encode a value
using the log odds of the good for the
bad
[Music]
okay so following feature engineering an
important part of the machine learning
pipeline is figuring out which features
need to end up in the final model
as a result of feature engineering the
data scientists may have hundreds if not
thousands of features in the data frame
and figuring out the most parsimonious
and predictive feature set takes a lot
of work
here we tested out five different
approaches
the first was an ensemble approach in
which we created a weighted average of
feature importance from six different
algorithms to get the feature set down
to 100 features
and then use extreme boosts and shots to
find the optimal feature set
next week we tested prediction value
change
which is how much on average the
prediction changes if the feature value
changes
followed by loss function change which
is a difference between the metric or
loss function
obtained with the feature and without
moving on we tested permutation
importance
where we measure the increase in the
prediction error after
permitting the features values and then
finally
shaft which is a game theory approach
using local explanations
i wanted to quickly show you an example
of how the feature selection process
looks using ml flow you can see here a
scatter plot
of model runs logged beginning with 100
features and using stepwise
backward feature selection you can see
how the model performance changes while
eliminating one feature at a time
secure the key here is to select the
smallest or least amount
of features and then the highest auc
here is a chart displaying the model
statistics auc and f1
on each of the different feature
selection tests we completed
in summary we were able to find the
optimal feature set using
feature selection with ensembl approach
and then used h2o's auto ml to find the
optimal hybrid parameters resulting in a
final x2
x2 boost model with target encoding
on this slide i want to go into a little
more detail
on machine learning model
interpretability machine learning models
are extremely complex
non-linear models in our work we often
use random forest and gradient boosted
machines
which means there can be hundreds of
trees with many feature
interactions which increases the model
complexity
when we talk about interpretation we can
say that
traditional statistical models are able
to give us global models
or models that can tell us how something
behaves in general
this makes sense because with regression
when we're talking
uh sorry we are taking a set of data
points and fitting a straight linear
line
through that data to explain the trends
on the other hand
machine learning models give local
behavior and are able to explain
complex relationships in local areas of
our data
with the interpretability methods we'll
review next we can harness the power of
increased accuracy and machine learning
while also being able to explain what's
going on at an account level basis
i also couldn't mention machine learning
interpretability without mentioning
patrick hall
go check out his github repo to see a
lot of great examples of machine
learning interpretability
continuing the discussion of
interpretation
one of the techniques that we all use
here at sats for machine learning
interpretability is shaft which stands
for shaftly additive explanation
and was created by scott lundberg using
shaft
you can explain the output from any
machine learning model
shapley plots originate from coalitional
game theory and calculate the marginal
contribution of each feature to an
overall prediction
before we go deeper into our model
interpretation i want to discuss with
you
how regulatory compliance impacts our
models given we work for finance company
to ensure that our model does not
violate fair lending constraints
special attention must be given to
protected features
for this project we went through the
entire model build process
including these protected features
highlighted above
to demonstrate the impact this plot
this chat plot sorts features by the sum
of the shot value magnitude over
all samples and uses strat values to
show the distribution of the impact
that each feature will have on the model
output
the color represents the feature value
with red being high and blue being low
you can see that there is distinct
separation for both age and gender and
how it relates to the target
for this reason the features are not
included in the final model
there could be a whole other
presentation about how we make sure that
our models don't negatively impact our
customers
after explicitly excluding these
protected features but that's a
conversation for another day
so taking that shop chat plot uh example
that chelsea just showed
previously uh shot plots can be great at
allowing us to globally understand how
important are features
in the model uh on these two plots here
i'm showing the
global shap and porn plots
both in the validation and the test set
and you can see
that generally these two plots are very
similar
there are some slight deviations in
the order such as like a mount down
payment
uh is below sk dpd
default on the test set where on the
validation set amount down payment
is above uh but generally these
values track very similarly across these
two data sets
so one of the things that i'd like to do
when i'm looking at how do i want to
model this data is actually try to
identify
do i have any features that are very
noisy being
that in one split of the data they
behave
in one way but perhaps in another split
of the data it looks very different
that's something that could be a red
flag because if you have a noisy feature
it likely won't generalize well to
unseen data
in the future uh secondly next step that
i would do with these
plots is actually then talk to business
domain experts
to understand do these features look
reasonable uh
these x source features x source 2 and
x-source 3
are features that we understand appear
to be related to credit scoring data
from our data set and then next uh
also you'll notice there's some features
here with the underscore te
and chelsea talked a little bit about
target encoding earlier which is one of
the feature engineering
techniques that we did on our data set
and so
an example of how that actually played
out in this data set
is the occupation type te feature
and on occupation type te
we had different values for
target encoded values for the
categorical values in this feature so
for instance
uh there was a categorical value for
occupation type
of accounts and then there was a
categorical value
of drivers in this feature
and drivers had a default rate right at
about 11
11.1 where accounts had a default rate
of 3.6
uh so by providing that information to
the model what the default rate is
uh this feature engineering technique is
one of the most powerful feature
engineering techniques you can do
on categorical data the target encoder
that we used was the open source h2o
target encoder
which also provides advantages in
allowing us to perform smoothing and
adding random noise
with cross validation target encoding
can easily overfit
if these types of approaches are not
implemented
so by invoking cross-validation with
random noise and smoothing
we can help our target encoded data
generalize better
to the future
and on this plot here we can get an
overview of features which are most
important
for a model we're plotting the shaft
values of every feature for every sample
the plot sort features by the sum of
shaft value magnitudes over all samples
and use chat values to show the
distribution of the impacts each feature
has on the model output the color
represents the feature value
with red being high and blue being low
the y-axis
is sorted by global feature importance
so the most important features
are at the top of the plot i talked a
little bit about target encoding uh
earlier on the prior slide and and so
since
target encoding is providing information
with respect to the target feature
uh we know that feature values that are
high uh
shown in here is red so like this
organization type
te feature those features that have red
values
are going to be features that have are
are going to be categorical values that
have higher
uh default rates than organization type
categorical values that are in blue
which would be lower default rates
this also allows us to understand that
the red valued
observations here are providing a
positive
marginal contribution to a default
prediction
and then also we can take a look here
with this plot and understand the
distribution of our data well too
so for instance here if we take a look
at occupation type
and name education type two features
that are very similar
in global importance being right next to
each other uh we can see that the
occupation type
te feature uh has
most of the data just left of the 0.0
uh point on the axis of
uh marginal contributions so these most
of the data set
is slightly uh providing a marginal
contribution to a no default prediction
conversely on the name education type te
feature you can see a bubble here
just slightly to the right of 0.0 so
these
observations are providing a small
marginal contribution
towards a default prediction the other
aspect that's really great about this
plot is you can get an understanding
of outliers and how values
provide more contribution to a
prediction
such as if we look at occupation type te
the high target encoded values there
have are further towards the right side
of the x-axis
on shot value than the high name
education type
te values so those features are more
significant
uh in the contribution of
a default prediction than the high
target encoded
name education type features are
the dependence plot allows us to
understand how a single feature
affects the output of the model the
shaft dependence plots shown here
show that as x-source 2 and x-source 3
values increase the shaft values
generally decrease
as you can see here going downwards
however uh we can also see a very
interesting
shape to the shot plot for the third
most important feature
a mount annuity x and as you can see
here
the amount annuity x feature shows that
chat values can take a very non-linear
shape where the maximum shaft values on
this feature are right at about 42 000
and a feature value with a value above
42 000 or below 42
000 is going to provide a marginal
contribution that will be
less likely to default than a feature
that would have
a value around 42 000.
interactions on these features with the
most significant other feature
are also represented on these plots in
the vertical dispersion of the plot so
you can see here
that these very high contribution
features here
on amount annuity x if
if the amount goods price x is also high
that's
providing an even greater lift towards a
marginal contribution of a default
prediction
um and then you can see other values
here such as
an x source three there are some values
that have
lower chat values then other values here
and that's indicative of this
interaction with this xsource1 feature
so we've talked a lot about model
interpretability
today we'd like to then conclude our
presentation with a demonstration of how
you can
tie model interpretability with
streamline
streamlit is a user interface that
is very exciting it's uh was introduced
at pi data los angeles last december
uh stream apps are python scripts run
from top to bottom
each time a user opens your app the
script is re-executed
uh as the script executes stream draws
its output live in a browser
and there is a widget functionality that
allows the user to provide
uh simulations and you can do what-if
modeling
uh with uh streamline so
uh as you can see here in this schematic
here basically
the script is run data is stored to
cache and
the app state is outputted and rendered
in the browser
and then as the user engages with the
app
that new data then is stored to cache
and a new state in the
app is rendered in a browser so
for this project here we were really
thinking it might be interesting to see
how
can we represent uh a model
and how it changes in feature values
uh in a form that a business user could
engage with and streamlit provides the
perfect solution
so we can do what-if simulations and
there's different types of
use cases for what-if simulations of a
machine learning model
myself or chelsea us as data scientists
we can use streamlined performance
sensitivity analysis
so we can identify how our model will
perform on a range of simulated values
so that there will be no surprises when
we bring the model to production
and this is an approach that chelsea
mentioned patrick hall talked in the
past about
many of his great interpretability
techniques sensitivity analysis is just
one of them
uh and here i've just kind of extended
that sensitivity analysis and tied it in
with streamline
uh if we want to talk about business
users using streamlit
we could talk about a use case where a
finance company could have credit
analysts determine what levers could
they use
when they're reviewing an application
and identify
if they can adjust aspects of that
application
that could result in an application that
would previously be denied
to an approval state and then thirdly
operations
executives can use streamlin to
understand how changes in performance
during key touch points in a customer
experience
could result in an impact to their
likelihood to be retained
increased share of wallet and
word-of-mouth referrals that customers
may provide
as and their aspect of their experience
with the business
at key operational touch points uh
changes
so with that we'd like to now actually
move into a live demo
of streamlight so
what we're showing here is um
an app that we built in streamlin it was
very
minimal code we were able to implement
this with
under 150 lines of python code uh
streamlet provides the ability to take
user input
so here i've inputted an application
this application number of 262266
on the data set and the first data frame
is showing
the prediction that is being rendered
from the model
the probability of no default and the
probability of default
the threshold on this model is right at
0.1315 so this
this prediction is rendering a default
prediction but it's not that far off
from getting a no default prediction
below that we're then actually rendering
in a data frame each of the features
that were used in the model
the observation value that was for this
row of data
and also the shaft value so negative
shaft values are
contributing to a no default prediction
and as i scroll down here on this data
frame you can see
positive values are contributing towards
a default prediction
and then later on we can actually then
look at in a real nice plot this is an
altair plot
how do those shaft values appear plotted
out
where again blue bars indicate features
are contributing to no default
prediction
uh red bars with higher shaft values are
contributing to
a default prediction and
next then we can perform sensitivity
analysis
or what-if analysis to actually see what
happens
if we were to change some of these
values in
this row of data and how does that
impact the
prediction and the probabilities that
are outputted from our machine learning
model
so these five sliders here that i'm
rendering which happen to be the five
most important features in the model
you can see again this observation is
still showing a
a 0.17 probability of default
but as we were engaging with uh this
application one of the things that we
found that was very striking here
is this fifth feature x-source one
if we move this value just down very
slightly just one
level lower the probability of default
jumps from 0.17
to 0.22
and conversely uh as
one of the use cases that i mentioned
earlier was credit analysts may want to
use
uh this to actually see how could i
get the applicant to modify their
applications so that their application
which was in a denial or a rejection
state could
potentially change to an approval state
and
one way that we could do this is with
streamlin an analyst could actually
manipulate
some of these values so let's say amount
annuity x is the amount that the
applicant is requesting uh credit for
if we were to move this value lower and
move this down to right at about 14
000 you'll see once i just get down to
below 14 000 also now this prediction is
now
changed to a no default prediction uh i
mentioned earlier that the
threshold was right at about 42 000 for
maximum
marginal contributions this was the
feature that had that non-linear
uh hump shape and so if we move
uh this value higher you'll start to see
the probability of default decline
so if i move this to say like 60 000
that probability comes down to 0.211 and
similarly if we go
under 42 000 that probability is also
around 0.213 but as you can see as we
move that right up to about 42 000 it
starts to spike a little bit
so that gives us also a very good
understanding of how this model is
behaving
uh other features that you could see
here are the other two very important
features of x source two and x source
three
and as we manipulate these feature
values too you could see okay if this
applicant let's say these are credit
features if this applicant had better
credit which
uh is denoted by a lower value on this
uh this feature the probability of
default is excuse me
better credit is higher value worst
credit would be a lower value so if we
start moving this down to a lower value
you can see the probability default
starts to spike significantly and one of
the great things about this
uh application here is all the values
update
dynamically in real time so as i change
these values let's say
if i look at x source 3 and i move this
value from 0.7463 and you can see
currently
x source 3 is providing the most
significant
marginal contribution to a no default
prediction
if i move this value to a lower value
which is going to contribute more
towards that default prediction
this alter plot is going to update
dynamically in real time so if i move
that down to 0.4673
all of a sudden x source uh 3 is it's
still higher but the bar's starting to
come down and then if i move it even
further
now x-source three is now the fourth
most important feature
and if i move this even further down
x-source three now will be
changing colors from blue to red and now
it's contributing to a default
prediction and let's say if i was to
move this even further down let's say
down
around 0.10 it will be
close to the most important feature and
if we move it all the way down
it will now be
the most important feature contributing
to a default prediction
so this really gives us a great deal of
power in seeing how we can adjust
features with sensitivity analysis and
understanding their impact
uh through shop at the marginal
contributions to
uh the prediction that is being
outputted from the machine learning
model
other couple examples i just want to
show here is let's take an example of an
applicant
that is very likely to not default
and if i enter an application number
here you can see
this plot now showing mostly blue bars
where the feature values are
contributing to no default prediction
very few features are contributing to a
default prediction
and you can see the probability of
default is .0036
one of the aspects of the way i built
the sensitivity analysis in this plot is
that
the what if modeling here is
being populated by the mean values in
the data set so you can see if the five
most significant features
for this observation had the mean value
instead of the actual value
that probability of default increased
from .0036 to
0.0897 which is interesting still no
default prediction but it's higher
and then you can see here again if i was
to move a value let's say x source 2
to a much higher value it's going to
bring that probability of default
down and becomes the most significant
feature of no default
if i make it a much lower value it's
going to
then get a default prediction and you
can see xsource2 will be
the most significant feature towards a
default prediction
and then lastly i can show let's take a
look at an observation that is very
likely to
have a default prediction this applicant
has
out of the model 72.3 probability of
default being outputted from the model
and you can see that uh very few
features are providing marginal
contribution towards no default
most providing a marginal contribution
towards default
uh so uh there's definitely i think a
lot of
opportunity for uh streamlet uh to
really help us as data scientists have a
better and deeper understanding
of our models but also interactively
demonstrate our models to the business
as we work on our machine learning
projects
and with that that concludes my
presentation
you